[Music]
so I'm going to read you something I get
some I had a lot of mail and I don't
know where I got this I've been a lot of
different places in the last week and
this showed up at one of them and I'm
going to read it to you I have no idea
what to make of it it's written in a
female hand so that's about all I can
tell but there's no address or name on
it this isn't a question but a comment
or more accurately perhaps a message I
spent this past weekend in an ayahuasca
ceremony which for those of you who
don't know is a South American visionary
plant medicine some of you may roll your
eyes at this but ayahuasca brings you
into direct contact with the archetypal
realm of being users of this medicine
initiates I should say refer to
ayahuasca as she because the spirit of
the plant is decidedly feminine an
encounter with ayahuasca is an encounter
with the great mother of creation the
goddess the void from which all things
come the feminine counterpart of logos
dr. Peterson you appeared in one of my
ayahuasca visions
might account for why I've being ripped
rather fatigued lately dr. Peterson you
appeared in one of my ayahuasca visions
and I asked asked her who is Jordan
Peterson what is he doing which is
something I'd really like to know as
well and she responded with crystalline
clarity quote here he is here to invoke
and initiate the divine masculine
principle on earth at this time so I'm
up here to thank you deeply and
profoundly on behalf of the Great Mother
herself to goddess the Divine Feminine
principle who has been eagerly awaiting
the awakening of the masculine principle
into divinity and service so you know
get a letter like that every day
actually I get a letter to like that
every day so you know what went through
my head when I read this and this is of
course and completely crazy parallel but
we know one of the things I learned to
do as a psychotherapist was just to tell
people who were talking to me what came
into my head it isn't what I'm thinking
exactly because that's not exactly the
same thing you know what comes into your
head is more like a dream it comes
unbidden it's like your imagination if
you're thinking there seems to be like a
voluntary element of that right I mean
some who god only knows how we think but
it seems partly voluntary at least and
Jung thought about Carl Jung thought
about it like a dialogue between the
conscious mind and the unconscious mind
there is a constant continual dialogue
but when things just pop into your mind
it's not much different than walking
into a room having something there which
is an observation I also derived from
Jung by the way because he pointed out
quite rightly that people don't really
think that thoughts appear to them
now you can think because you can take
the thoughts that appear to you and then
you can subject them to criticism and
elaboration and so on instead of just
assuming that they're true right off the
bat but people often don't do that they
just something just pops into their head
and then they assume that it's true
anyways one of the things that I tend to
do in psychotherapy is just to tell
people what pops into my head because
well why because then the person that is
talking to me gets one person's
untrammeled opinion not even that
reaction not opinion it's not really an
opinion I don't think an opinion maybe
is what I think later and there's this
personal flavor to it what popped into
my head was the story about Socrates you
know he had this when he was being put
on trial by the Athenians for corrupting
the nation's youth something I've been
accused of by the way although it's not
self-evident to me that it's me doing
the corrupting he said that somebody had
asked him once had asked the Delphic
Oracle once and the Delphic Oracle was
this retreat that you could go to if you
were an ancient Greek citizen and you'd
be there and you'd have a dream and then
you'd go ask the Delphic Oracle to
interpret it and nobody really knows
what was up with the Delphic Oracle
today how that worked exactly but she
would interpret your dream in any case
and somebody once asked her who the
wisest man in Greece was and the Delphic
Oracle said it was Socrates because he
knew he didn't know anything that's
essentially the story not popped into my
mind
it's a crazy comparison but you know I
have a crazy mind so I guess that's how
it works out so now one of the things
I'm going to do today which I haven't
done before because I'm going to read
you a little bit of I told you I
finished my book last week and I haven't
read it read it to anyone I have given
it to a couple of friends to review one
person in particular screenwriter named
Greg Hurwitz has been unbelievably
helpful he's so fast and so sharp at
this sort of thing and I can send him
like a twenty page dense twenty page
manuscript and he'll rip it to shreds
and send it back to me in like 90
minutes it's just unbelievable he's so
good at that he's been very helpful but
I haven't no one else has seen it apart
from my editor and I haven't read it to
anyone so but some of it seemed
particularly appropriate for tonight's
lecture so I thought I would start the
lecture tonight by reading a little
bitter that and it's it's from a chapter
it's on the issue of sacrifice as such
this is Abraham and Isaac this is a very
strange little Testament story right
this is one of the stories that's
contained in the Old Testament that
makes modern people think that maybe we
should just not have that punch to do
with the Old Testament per say it at all
and especially with regards and maybe
you shouldn't have anything to do with
the God of the Old Testament either
because I mean as far as Abraham is
concerned God tells him to sacrifice his
own son now it turns out that God was
just kidding so to speak you know I'm
obviously being flippant but you know it
does raise the question what do you make
of a divine being who would who would
require such thing such a thing or
conversely what do you make of Abraham
who would have such delusions either way
it's a little hard on the what would you
call modern believability and moral
integrity of the Old Testament but these
are very very strange stories and
they're not what they seem to be or they
are but and they're more so we're going
to talk a lot about sacrifice tonight
and here's some of the things that I've
been thinking about sacrifice so this is
from this book it's called twelve rules
for life an antidote for chaos and it's
coming out in January which I think I
mentioned and this is from rule 7 which
is do what is meaningful not what is
expedient and so here's here's some of
the writing I've been doing over the
last three years on meat on the motif of
sacrifice I'll start with just a brief
intro before I read this
it took me a long time to understand
what was meant in the Old Testament by
sacrifice and which is strange because
once I figured it out it seemed bloody
obvious it seemed like oh yo obviously
that's what it means but lots of times
if you figure something out correctly it
seems self-evident as soon as you've
figured it out
correctly well we'll see how that goes
but you know it seemed to work for me
anyways
I knew that of course at least
implicitly I knew of the modern usage of
the idea of sacrifice everyone
understands that motif is that if you
want to make things better in the future
then you suck make sacrifices in the
present and maybe you even do that
multi-generationally in fact you most
definitely do if you're a good parent
I mean you and that's just I would say
that's a really particularly typical of
of immigrants right because immigrants
often come from terrible places and have
to undergo terrible things to come to a
new community where they get a rough
reception and have a hard time getting
their life going and a big part of the
reason that they do it is to make their
lives of their children better and
luckily when they come to Canada usually
given where they came from that actually
works because where they came from is
worse and here is better even though no
you know immigrants often have to
struggle to to get on their feet again
have to learn a new language and become
acculturated and face the fact that
they're not part of the mainstream
culture and well you know many of you
know the whole story so the idea that
you make sacrifices for the future and
you make sacrifices for your children
and that's everyone understands without
and it's part of being responsible and
mature and shouldering the burden of
being properly and you do that for
yourself too if you're disciplined in
fact that's almost what discipline means
it discipline means that you're capable
of making sacrifices because you're not
disciplined if you just do something you
want more rather than something that
you're doing that's not discipline
that's maybe that works and great if
your life is working out that way great
man but that isn't that isn't discipline
this is plan is when you want to do
something right now and instead you
think no I'm going to force
all my gratification maybe forever
but certainly for a very long period of
time medium to long period of time and
you concentrate on something that you
think will bear fruit in the medium to
long run and so you look into the future
and you decide that by making today a
little less impulsively pleasurable
shall we say you'll make tomorrow a
little bit more secure and productive
and then you actually do it too and
that's difficult you know and we
discussed last week Adam and Eve's
discovery of the future and and the
revelation of the possibility of the
future including the possibility of
tragedy and suffering in the future and
and it's our knowledge of the
possibility of tragedy and suffering in
the future that motivates us to
sacrifice in the present so that we can
reduce the unnecessary anxiety and
uncertainty and pain that awaits us now
that's a negative way of putting it
we're also doing it so that you know we
can have some joy and we can make life
better in all of that and and that's not
trivial but the fundamental issue
especially once you have small children
this fundamental issue is to save the
suffering the hell off right that's what
you want to do that's your primary moral
obligation if you're a person who has
any if your eyes are open at all that's
your primary obligation and so you make
the sacrifices that are necessary and
you set up the future and well the the
motif of sacrifice is there in the Old
Testament but it's more it's so concrete
that it's difficult to draw a parallel
between the two at least for me they
didn't align self-evidently and I don't
remember in my rather limited religious
education as a child in the United
Church because I went to the United
Church till I was about 13 I don't ever
remember anybody pointing out that like
the sacrifices that Cain and Abel were
making or the sacrifice that Abraham was
supposed to make or sacrifices that
people were making to God
were the car were the precursors let's
say the dramatic precursors to the
psychological idea of
Accra Feist that we all hold as
civilized people in the modern world so
although it seems obvious as I said once
you lay it out it I don't remember that
ever being explained to me but and then
well and then let me read this so now
that I've sort of introduced it here's
what happened as humanity developed
first were the endless tens or hundreds
of thousands of years prior to the
emergence of written history and drama
the twin practices of delay and exchange
began to emerge slowly and painfully so
here's a cool psychological study so
it's called the marshmallow test and
maybe it's even a reliable study even
though it was done by social
psychologists it's probably replicable
um and it's a nice study so you take
small children and you bring them into a
room and you put something that they
would like in front of them a
marshmallow and you then you torture
them basically you say see that
marshmallow and the kid thinks yeah I
see that marshmallow it's like you can
have that marshmallow right now or if
you wait I think the experiment is ten
minutes then you can have two
marshmallows and so that puts the child
in quite a conundrum because they're
being asked to trade an actual concrete
tangible marshmallow for two
hypothetical future marshmallows and
it's not that easy to conjure up a
hypothetical future reality that has the
same tangible significance as something
real right in front of you and so it's
amazing thing that people can do that
and so then the experimenter leaves and
some children grab the marshmallow and
just you know chomp that thing down
right now other kids they videotape kids
while they're waiting and they do all
sorts of things they whistle they look
at the ceiling they sit on their hands
you know they try to distract themselves
course they're eyeing that marshmallow
like a squirrel lying and not and and
trying to restrain themselves and you
know what I see in that is that the
child's prefrontal cortex
the higher cortical systems are warring
with the underlying motivational systems
more primordial motivational systems
that govern such things as Hunger the
hunger system hypothalamic system says
there is something sweet and fat right
sitting there right bloody now grab that
thing and stuff it down now and I'm sure
many of you have a constant battle with
your hypothalamus with regards to sweet
and fat things and often lose so you can
feel some sympathy for the child but and
the hypothalamus has these tremendously
powerful tendrils upward into the brain
into the parts that we would associate
more with voluntary control and the
voluntary control centers have these
little weak ribbons going down to
control the hypothalamus since it's
pretty obvious if you know something
about neuroanatomy what part is actually
in charge when the chips are down and
it's not easy for children to learn to
regulate those underlying primordial
impulses the ones that are wired in the
ones that we share with animals but they
do it and and and the cool thing is this
is what Walter Mischel found he's the
guy who did the study was that the
long-term outcome for the children who
can delay gratification in the
marshmallow test is much more positive
than it is for the children that are
impulsive and eat the marshmallow
instantly its delay of gratification now
it's likely that that's associated with
trait conscientiousness although that
specifically has that specific
connection has not yet been established
but they seem conceptually very very
similar so so anyways this emerges and
children probably between the ages of 2
and 4 something like that they should
have it in place by four because it's
very difficult for them to really
interact well with other children
without having that delay of
gratification in place because you can't
delay gratification other kids don't
like you because you're you want
everything your way and you want it now
and your lot you're liable to temper
tantrums and that sort of thing you
haven't got the kind of self-control
necessary to make you fun to play with
so you can see that emerging in children
and it's pretty it's pretty interesting
and and not only that if it
it predicts positive long-term outcomes
just like trade conscientiousness does
by the way because trade
conscientiousness is the second best
predictor of long-term success over the
lifespan in Western cultures its second
after intelligence and so in our
societies the people who do best across
time are the people who have high IQs
and who work hard and I would say that's
a pretty decent what would you call it
it's a validation in some sense that our
cultures are working properly because
what you would want I would say if the
system is working meritocratic ly like
it should and if you're trying to
extract resources from those who can
contribute at a higher rate than what
you would want to have happen is that
the hard-working smart people do better
hopefully if that's the case then
everyone does better hopefully anyways
so you can see this developing in
children first where they endless tens
or hundreds of thousands of years prior
to the emergence of written history and
drama the twin practices of delay and
exchange began to emerge slowly and
painfully then they became represented
in metaphorical abstraction as rituals
and tales of sacrifice it's as if
there's a powerful figure in the sky
who's judging you you better keep him
happy or look the hell out we've been
watching ourselves deal with him for a
long time he seems to like it when you
give up something you value so practice
sharing and sacrificing until you get
good at it no one actually said any of
this so long ago although they said
something very similar but it was
implicit in the practice and then in the
stories action comes first
implicit comes first people watched the
successful succeed and the unsuccessful
fail for thousands and thousands of
years and we thought it over and we drew
a conclusion the successful among us
sacrifice the successful among us delay
gratification
a successful among us bargain with the
future and then a great idea begins to
emerge in ever more articulated form
that idea is the point of a long and
profound story it's the moral of this
story and I'm going to engage in some
foreshadowing here what's the difference
between the successful and the
unsuccessful the successful sacrifice
and things get better as the successful
practice their sacrifices the question
becomes increasingly precise and
simultaneously broader what is the
greatest possible sacrifice for the
greatest possible good you know if you
if you push a question in a direction
perhaps there comes a time when you
can't formulate it any more precisely
and broadly and and that that's the
point at which the question in some
sense and perhaps even the answer the
question becomes our katha pollitt it
becomes archetypal because it it can't
be bested
and this is like an ultimate question in
some sense how are you going to ask a
more broad-based question than that what
is given the initial presuppositions
that you have to make sacrifices then
the logical end point to that is
something like okay if you have to make
a sacrifice what's the greatest possible
sacrifice and for the greatest possible
good that's a good question
the answer becomes increasingly profound
for the god of Western tradition like so
many gods requires sacrifice we've
already examined why but sometimes he
goes even further and requires the
sacrifice of what is loved best this is
why and this is another one of mankind's
fundamental discoveries sometimes things
do not go well that that's self-evident
but here's the rub sometimes when things
are not going well it's precisely that
which is most valued that is the cause
why it's because the world is revealed
through the template of your values if
the world you are seeing is not the
world you want
therefore it's time to examine your
values it's time to rid yourself of your
current presuppositions there's a famous
experiment that I've alluded to a couple
of times I believe in this lecture
series the invisible gorilla experiment
and in the invisible gorilla experiment
there's two teams of players each with
three members one dressed in block and
the other dressed in white and each team
is passing a basketball back and forth
to the team members and milling about
you see a video of them doing so they
basically fill the video screen and the
White team is passing a basketball to
the white team members and the Black
team is passing a basketball to the
Black team members and your job as as
far as the experimenter is concerned is
for you to count the number of times
that the black block team yes black team
passes the basketball back and forth so
that's what you do so now you have an
ambition and a name and a value and the
ambition and the aim and the value
they're all the same thing and that is
to perform well at the task now the
thing that's so cool about this and this
is really so cool it's just unbelievably
it's just unbelievable that this is the
case it's like a complete validation of
a certain element of the Buddhist
worldview so they passed the ball for a
couple of minutes and then the
experimenter says to you how many and
you say 15 and because you're happy and
you're happy with yourself because
you've been paying attention and and the
experimenter says yeah that's right or
maybe not maybe you missed one and then
the experimenter says did you see the
gorilla and half of you say what what
what your real eye like really and he's
in the experimenter says yes and then he
rewinds it and plays the video and like
a minute and a half into the 3-minute
video
sure enough in walks this guy in a
gorilla suit six foot three or so stands
in the middle of the game right in the
middle of the game the same size as the
players perfectly obviously evident the
his chest for like a second and a half
and then sort of saunters off and half
the people who watch the video don't see
the gorilla and which is absolutely
shocking and what that means is that
your ambitions blind you to the nature
of reality
now they illuminate some reality but
they blind you to most of it and that's
fine because you're not does not allow
to you in some ways you're a very
pinpoint thing like a laser beam and so
you just can't be attending to
everything all the time
but one of the things that you might ask
yourself once you know that is that if
you're suffering dreadfully then one
possibility is that you're so fixed on
the point you're so fixed on a point the
fact that you're so fixed on the point
that you're fixed on might be integrally
related to why things are going so
catastrophic aliy wrong now perhaps not
because you know there's a lot of
arbitrariness about life and perhaps you
suffer even when you don't deserve to
that seems to happen in the book of Job
for example because job is a good guy
and God has a bet with Satan which seems
like another relatively nasty thing to
do to let's say it just torture and he
does quite nicely to see if he'll turn
against God and it seems like a rather
playground sort of thing for God to
engage in but the point is is that even
in a document like the Old Testament
there's ample suggestion that sometimes
people just get wiped out and hurt even
if they're living good moral lives
aiming properly and all that there's an
arbitrariness in life you that's not it
erratic low but it's possible that it's
what you're clinging to that's hurting
you and it's even possible that's the
thing that you're clinging to the
hardest that's hurting you the most that
could easily be someone you love like
lots of times I see people in therapy
and they're miserable for one reason or
another sometimes it's because they have
a very close relationship with a family
member and that just isn't working you
know the family member for the sake of
simplicity will say is not really
oriented towards helping them have a
good life the
family member is instead oriented
towards making them as bloody miserable
as you can possibly make anyone and and
what would you say exploiting the the
bond between family members in order to
enable that and then sometimes the
sacrifice that's necessary is either
merely distancing yourself from that
person sometimes substantively and
sometimes seriously distancing yourself
from like we don't talk anymore ever and
so that's pretty damn rough and it hurts
and all of that but but it's a good
example of the fact that sometimes in
order to extract yourself from the
miserable bit of chaos that you happen
to be enmeshed in you have to let go of
what you love best if the world you are
seeing is not the world you want
therefore it's time to examine your
values that's really worth it's really
worth thinking about you know because
the alternative to is to curse fate
right because if it isn't you and
there's nothing you can do to change
there isn't something you're doing
that's wrong then it's faith itself it's
the world itself it's other people let's
say because they're a huge part of the
world or it's the nature of the world
itself or or its God himself in whatever
form you either believe in or don't
believe in because it's fundamentally
all the same in the sort of situation
that I'm describing so and one of the
things that's really interesting and I
mentioned this before about the
Israelites in the Old Testament is that
they they got this right it's really
something because what happens to the
Israelites over and over in the Old
Testament is that they get all puffed up
about how wonderful they are and then
they make moral errors because they're
arrogant and then God comes along and
just cuts them into pieces for like
generation after generation and then
they wobble back to their feet and but
they always maintain the same attitude
which is we did something wrong we did
something wrong it's like it's like it's
like an axiom rather than observation is
that if we're not if things are not
laying themselves out for us as they
should be then we cannot curse god we
have to look to ourselves
well you think well why not curse God
because maybe it's his fault that's a
really good question and one of the
things that I've tried to figure out
over the last 30 years is well why not
just curse God because there is this
arbitrary element to existence and we
are vulnerable and there is a plenty of
suffering and things are unfair like
there's problems right there's injustice
and unfairness and all of these things
and endless suffering so why not just
lay at the feet of God and the whether
God exists or not in some sense by the
way with regards to the metaphysics of
this particular discussion is not
relevant it's the point remains the same
either way and the answer is as far as I
can tell that if you refuse to take on
the responsibility yourself and you
attempt it to lay it at the feet of
either society or being itself then you
instantly start to act in a way that
makes everything much worse not only for
you but for everyone else and maybe even
for being itself and so no it's not
helpful now if you're if you decide that
it's you you've got the problem maybe
that's not even true like maybe you are
someone who's being tortured by the bet
between God and Satan and like too bad
for you if that happens to be the case
but it still seems to be the appropriate
thing for a human being who's standing
on his or her own two feet in a proper
manner to take the responsibility on for
themselves regardless of the
counter-arguments that might be made
against it that's really something
it's time to rid yourself of your
current presuppositions I also think of
that it's a deadwood issue you know one
of the things you see with motifs like
the pair of the Phoenix
remember when Harry Potter goes off to
fight he's like st. George he goes off
to fight the the hell is that thing the
basilisk that turns you to stone when
you look at it's a dragon for all
intents and purposes its guarding a
virgin bird what's her name for it's not
Virginia it's close to that though Ginny
Ginny Ginevra right which is a variant
of virgin and very introvert for jigna
well when he gets bitten
by the dragon and poisoned that's the
dragon of chaos right the thing that
turns you to stone when you look at it
when he gets bitten by it then he's
going to die and yeah well if you get
bitten by the thing that turns you to
stone when you look at it if it bites
you man if you're not dead you're going
to wish you are it's one of the two and
then the Phoenix flies in and cries
tears into the wound and that heals them
and the Phoenix is the thing that allows
the dead wood to burn off occasionally
let's say well it's I think it's once
every hundred years with the Phoenix and
of course it's pretty dramatic the whole
damn bird has to go up in flames and
then there's nothing left but an egg but
there's a very serious message there too
which is that you know you can compare
yourself in some sense to a forest fire
to a forest you know in a forest has to
burn now and then for the deadwood to
clear so that the forest can actually
maintain its continued existence and if
you stopped the forest from burning for
a prolonged period of time which
happened in the United States when they
were trying to manage the forest fires
too tightly then all that happens is the
dead wood accumulates and accumulates
and accumulates and accumulates and
accumulates until the whole damn forest
is dead wood and then lightning hits it
and it burns so hot that it burns the
topsoil off and then there's nothing
left nothing grows and so that's a good
moral lesson which is don't wait too
long to let the damn dead wood burn off
you know maybe a little
self-immolation on a daily basis might
be preferable to burning yourself all
the way down to the bedrock you know
once every 20 years or so because maybe
there won't be anything left of you when
you do that and you know that happens to
people all the time I've seen that
happen to people many many times the
dead wood accumulates the mess around
them gathers the chaos that they haven't
dealt with accumulates and then one day
the spark comes and they burn so far and
so fast that there's not enough left of
them to recover and then they're the
people who've been eaten by the Beast
they're they're people who've been eaten
by the dragon and now are inside its
belly another very common archetypal
motif and well maybe a hero will come
along and rescue them or maybe they'll
just stay in there forever and that's a
precursor to the idea of Hell and it's
not something I would recommend so a
little medicine on a regular basis
is a lot better too than total emulation
on terms other than your own
sporadically it's time to rid yourself
of your current presuppositions there's
another segment see in the Soviet Union
with Solzhenitsyn wrote about the Soviet
Union comments pathologies it it's sort
of peaked in terms of its pathological
authoritarianism when it became illegal
to complain that your life wasn't going
well and you just think about how
horrible that is say because because you
know lots of times your life isn't going
well I mean and I don't mean this in
some casual way I mean maybe I don't
know maybe have diabeetus in your you
know maybe you're gonna lose your your
feet or something like it's really not
it's nothing trivial that's going on
here something is not good or maybe it's
economic or maybe you're unemployed or
and but you see the idea in the Soviet
Union was well we already have all the
answers everything's perfect already
that's what totalitarian is fake well if
everything is perfect and you're
suffering then well maybe there's
something wrong with you because
everything is perfect after all and if
you're suffering then what are you to
come out and say well I'm suffering it's
like well then your evidence that things
aren't perfect right
you're like a widow or an orphan in an
Old Testament story you know when the
Kings got to high and mighty then they
wouldn't pay enough attention to the
widows and the orphans and then the
profit would come along and say you know
those widows and orphans a lot more
important than you think they are and if
you don't pay attention to them properly
then things are going to fall apart
around you in a way that you just can't
even imagine and so well then you're
sort of like your own Widow and your own
orphan but you don't get say hey look
you know things aren't perfect yet
because I'm actually having still quite
a rough time here you don't get to admit
to your own suffering if you can't admit
to your own suffering then you certainly
see the suffering especially the
additional suffering the excess
suffering should be treated as evidence
that you're not doing something quite
right yet it should be treated as
evidence that you're wrong there's
something important that you're doing
that's
wrong I understand how harsh that is and
I'm not saying that everyone who's
suffering is suffering because they're
doing something in some simple way
that's wrong I was in a elevator once in
a hospital it's a very terrifying thing
and this person got on who was just in
an absolute state of shock you know I
mean it was really not good and I don't
remember how this happened but I engaged
the person in conversation and they just
said that they had just had been
diagnosed with what looked to be
terminal cancer and what was horrifying
about it was that what they were doing
was going over their life in the
elevator trying to figure out what they
had done in order to deserve such a fate
you know they've immediately taken it on
themselves as a moral failing and that's
not what I'm saying you can't come up to
someone who has cancer and say well if
you weren't such a bloody idiot
throughout your whole life you wouldn't
have cancer and believe me that happens
a lot more than you think
and people who have diseases like that
get blamed for it that's not what I'm
saying it's not like that it's it's it's
it's a more generalized attitude that is
that if life isn't yet what it should be
then you have a response you have a
primary responsibility to do something
about it and the place to start looking
is to your own errors and to fix them
and that's and that's that's that's a
safe bet man because you're probably
doing some things that you would
wouldn't have to be doing that if you
fixed would make things better
so it's time to let go and to sacrifice
who you are for who you could become
[Applause]
there's an old story about how to catch
a monkey in case any of you aren't
interested in how to catch a monkey now
you now you're going to know how to do
it first you have to take a large narrow
necked jar just large enough in diameter
at the top for a monkey to put its hand
inside then you have to fill it partway
with rocks so it's too heavy for the
monkey to carry then you scatter some
treats near the jar to attract them and
you put some inside inside the narrow
neck jar a monkey will come along if
you're lucky and grab the you know
goodies but he'll want the ones inside
the jar too so then put his hand in
there and grab what's in there and if
you've set up your monkey trap properly
then he won't be able to eat his hand
out because he's got good goodies
not without unclenching his hand not
without relinquishing what he already
has the monkey coucher can just walk
over and just pick up the monkey because
the monkey isn't into the whole
sacrifice thing because he's just a
monkey you know and so you can catch him
as a consequence of his own unregulated
hypothalamic desires you know and to be
what would you say charitable to the
monkey if you put out candy or something
like that's like how often does a monkey
get candy he's probably a little more
motivated than you are to not let go but
you can get the point
the monkey catcher can just walk over to
the jar and pick up the monkey the
animal will not sacrifice the part for
the whole that's actually a pretty good
phrase it's the animal that will not
sacrifice the part for the whole perhaps
this story is apocryphal but as an
eccentric psychology professor once told
me fiction lies to you in the most truth
in the most truthful possible manner
something valuable given up ensures
future prosperity something valuable
sacrificed pleases the Lord those are
equivalent statements ones more
articulated I would say that's the first
statement then the second one is more
dramatic and more embedded in a
collective religion
dream you might say what's most valuable
and best sacrifice well obviously that
depends on the culture and the time what
is at least emblematic of that a choice
cut of meat well if you're a herdsmen
for example that that's a big deal with
I mean generally speaking throughout
human history meat has been a very
valuable commodity as it is by the way
among chimpanzees chimpanzees hunt they
like to hunt colobus monkeys and you
know they'll they'll basically start
eating the damn monkey alive they weigh
about 40 pounds despite the fact that
the thing is screaming away and that's
pretty interesting because one of the
things that indicates is that male
monkeys that male chimps they're the
ones that do the hunting aren't really
inhibited that much when they're in
hunter mode by what you might describe
as empathy and there's certain elements
of human behavior that are reminiscent
of that you see that sort of thing
emerged now and then in human
battlefields when groups of men seem to
abandon all internal regulation
whatsoever
to a degree that makes you wonder if
internal regulation even exists so it's
kind of meat well meats valuable you
know and this is a good document by
Richard Wrangham I think while back a
book about the human invention of fire
and I think I told you a little bit
about this Wrangham claimed that we
invented fire discovered fire mastered
it maybe two or three million years ago
that's a long time longer than people
had thought and that that's what
actually transformed us physiologically
from our chimp-like ancestors into the
sort of svelte creatures we are now
because it's a lot easier to digest
cooked meat and meat is a tremendous
source of of nutrition energy raw
materials all of that especially if it's
cooked so me it's a big deal cook meat
is a big deal and maybe it's a choice
cut of meat the kind you might offer to
a guest if you're not a I always say
this wrong said vegan vegan or vagin I
always think vagin but that's wrong
that's that's a star vague as a star
right they're not like star creatures
they're they're yeah anyway so you know
you might offer that especially
especially if a guest came to your abode
and you were I heard man you might
sacrifice a high-end animal and offer
your guests a nice choice cut of meat
and that would actually matter it would
mean something from the best animal in a
flock what's above even that well in
terms of the thing you could sacrifice
well your best animal that's good well
how about you how about your child how
about you well that would be next on the
hierarchy it's kind of hard to get past
that right and I think it's a it's a
toss-up whether the sacrifice is greater
if it's you or if it's your child I
would say being a parent that it's
greater if it's your child because I
think most people who have established a
I hate I hesitate to say proper but I'm
going to anyway it's a proper
relationship with their children it's if
push came to shove they'd take the
bullet and let their kid go live the
sacrifice of the mother is exemplified
profoundly by Michelangelo's great
sculpture the PA de Mary is
contemplating her son crucified Andrews
so that's his body after he's been
crucified it's her fault it was through
her he entered the great dream of being
so what's the meaning of this sculpture
it's a great sculpture it's just an
absolutely unbelievable sculpture you
just can't believe that someone could
exist who could make something like and
of course it wasn't the only thing
Michelangelo made right it was like
that's it it was something he just
tossed off in a couple of months while
he was doing other unbelievable things
but you know it's it's an it's an object
of contemplation which is why it's in a
great Cathedral in a great city it's an
object of contemplation and the idea is
something like well what what's the role
of a mother if she's awake I had a
client come see me a while back not very
long ago woman in a boat who's about 30
and trying to make decisions about her
life she was pretty career oriented and
so I asked her about although maybe
having a bit of trouble with
career I've seen this many many times so
this is an amalgam this is a story
that's an amalgam and I talked to her
about the other elements of her life
it's like well you know there's only
five things you do in life so you've got
your career down you know what do you do
outside of your career that's meaningful
and engaging how are things going with
your family could be your family of
origin your siblings whatever if you
have an intimate relationship and like
what's your plan for your own family and
apart from those five things there's
sort of something like get some exercise
now and then don't eat too badly and try
to stay away from the drugs you know
that's that that kind of and the crime
that kind of lays out life and if you
miss any of those five things or if you
do any of those other things wrong then
you're in trouble and you can get away
with missing a couple of them but not
all of them you know and she said
something along the lines of well I'm
not sure I should bring a child into
this world I thought oh God Christ you
got to come up with something better
than that such a bloody cliche which is
what I told her I said you know you must
have thought that up when you were 16
it's like really that's here that you
can't do any better this is a very very
smart woman it's like really and this
can't do any better than that
like yes obviously this is a vale of
tears and you know a well of suffering
and all of that you know if you ask 30
people who are wondering about having
children why they're wondering 20 of
them will say that and so that that
tells you how original it is it's not
original at all it's not a thought it's
like this little it's like a it's like a
it's a mean something that lives in your
mind it's not a thought and it's
certainly not something it's certainly
not something that you should just take
it face value in and say oh well I'm not
having a family then it's like no no you
kind of look at that and you criticize
it a little bit it's like well the pop
it's the other one that's the other one
that's very common there's too many
people on the planet already I really
don't like that statement it's like just
who are you going to ask to leave just
how are you going to get them to leave
you know it's a serious question and who
says there's too many people what the
hell is wrong with people anyways so or
ruining the planet yeah it's like I
think it was the Club of Rome who who
prophesied by the way that there would
be so many people on the planet by the
year 2000 that there would be widespread
starvation and they were completely and
utterly wrong about that and I think it
was the Club of Rome who either compared
us to a virus or a cancer on the face of
the planet it's like oh really that's
what you think about people hmm
aren't you something isn't that
something to think about human beings
viruses and cancer what do you do with
viruses and cancer invite them in and
make them at home it's like no you try
to eradicate them you've got a bloody
well watch your metaphors folks because
it isn't clear that you come up with
them or that they run you so you better
watch them
so anyways Mary you know and Mary's the
great mother right that she's the mother
that's what Mary is whether she existed
or not is not the point she exists at
least as a hyper reality she exists as
the mother well what's the sacrifice of
the mother well that's easy if you're a
mother and you if you're a mother who's
worth her salt you offer your son to be
destroyed by the world that's what you
do that's what's going to happen right
he's going to be born he's going to
suffer he's going to have his trouble in
life he's going to have his illnesses
he's going to face his failures and
catastrophes and he's going to die
that's what's going to happen and if
you're awake you know that and then you
say well perhaps he will live in a way
that will justify that and then you try
to have that happen and that's what
makes you worthy of a statue like that
but still the sacrifice of the mother is
it right to bring a baby into this
terrible world well every woman asks
yourself that question some say no and
they have the reasons Mary answers yes
voluntarily Mary is the archetype of the
woman who answers yes to life
voluntarily that's what that image means
and not because she's blind she knows
what's going to happen and so she's the
archetypal representation of the woman
who says yes to life knowing full well
what what life is not naive not someone
who got pregnant in the backseat of the
1957 Chevy you know in one in a one
night of half-drunk idiocy not that but
consciously consciously knowing what's
to come
and then also allows it to happen
because that's another thing that's a
testament to the courage of mothers my
mother was good at this my mother's a
very agreeable person too agreeable for
her own good but that's what happens if
you're agreeable because you're too
agreeable if your own good that's the
definition of agreeable and so she's a
nice person and it still is luckily
she's still alive and we've had a very
good relationship and I have always been
able to make her laugh which is which is
a good thing and but she was tough
cookie that woman you know if if
remember once she came across I was out
playing in this baseball diamond little
diamond and empty lot really in this
little town I grew up in and I was about
ten and she walked by I was there with
bunch of my friends and I was about to
have a fistfight with this little tough
kid that I hung around with and there
were half girls on the team and this
fight had some relationship to status
maneuvering you know in relationship to
that anyways we're going to have a fight
and my mom walked by she took a look and
I could see from her demeanor that she
knew exactly what was about to happen
and she looked for a second and then she
walked by and I thought whoa good work
mom no kidding it's like last bloody
thing I needed at that moment was for
her to come charging up and say you boys
aren't planning to have a fight are you
it's like well yeah mom we're we were
actually planning to have a fight and
now that you came and intervened I
actually lost before the goddamn saying
even started
so two thumbs up for mom she was also
the person that said because I had some
trouble with my dad when I was you know
it adolescence he had some trouble with
me so you know it was 50/50 that's for
now it's probably 70/30 with me on the
seventy end of the being the trouble and
anyways I left home when I was about
seventeen and she said something really
interesting when I left home she said it
was too good at home you never leave I
thought hey mom that's pretty good you
know for for an agreeable person you've
got a real spine man so that was pretty
good
so so you know mother that's as this the
mother into the person who also says get
out there take your goddamn lumps
because you're tough enough so that you
can handle it she doesn't say you just
stay down there and your bedroom
brooding away because the world is
unfair and treating you badly and your
suffering is too much she says yeah
there's a lot of suffering out there but
you're a hell of a lot tougher than you
think you are so in turn Mary's son
Christ offers himself to God so
completely that his faith and trust in
the world is not broken by betrayal
torture or death that's the model for
the honorable man so you know you have
an interesting dynamic there you have
the woman who's willing to make the
sacrifice lays the groundwork for the
son who is willing to make the sacrifice
that works out pretty nicely and it's a
good thing to know in Christ's case
however as he sacrifices himself God his
father is simultaneously sacrificing his
son right that's one of the oddities of
the Trinitarian model is that God
sacrifices himself to himself same thing
happens in Norse mythology right Norse
Zeus Germanic mythology Zeus sacrifices
himself to himself he actually hangs on
a tree it's actually wounded in his side
it's very interesting parallel but I
think part of the idea is well the human
human race is starting to work out
what's the ultimate sacrifice it's
something like that ultimate sacrifice
of value well the the passion story and
I told you I was foreshadowing I'm
bringing cysts into consideration things
we won't talk about for a long time
maybe not at all in this lecture series
I don't know because I don't know how
far I'll get is that well there's a
supreme sacrifice demanded on the part
of the mother and there's a supreme
sacrifice demanded on the part of the
son and there's a supreme sacrifice
demanded on the part of the father all
at the same time and then that makes the
supreme sacrifice possible and
hypothetically that's the one that
renews that's the sacrifice that renews
and redeems it's a hell of an idea man
and the thing about it is that I don't
know if it's true but I know that its
opposite is false and generally the
opposite of something that's false is
true it's it's opposite as false it's
because if the mother doesn't make the
sacrifice then you get the horrible
eatable situation or something like that
in the household which is just its own
absolute catastrophic hell and if you
want a really good insight into that I
would say watch the documentary crumb
see ru and be a man that's been rated by
some critics as the best documentary
ever made and it is some piece of work
man it is the only thing I've ever seen
that actually lays out the eatable
catastrophe and it's full nightmare you
know so you could you could look at that
so if the maternal sacrifice isn't there
then that doesn't work if the paternal
sacrifice isn't there you know if you're
if the father isn't willing to put his
son out into the world let's say to be
broken and betrayed and all of those
things then that's a non-starter because
the kid doesn't grow up and then if the
son isn't willing to do that well then
who the hell is going to shoulder the
responsibility so if those three things
don't happen then it's cataclysmic it's
chaotic as hell if they do happen is it
the opposite of that well you could say
well maybe it depends on the degree to
which they happen and and it's a
continuum how thoroughly can they happen
well we don't know you know because you
might say how good a job do you do
of encouraging your children to live in
truth let's say well that's part of the
answer to this question and the answer
likely is well not you don't do as good
a job of it as you could so it works out
quite well but you don't know how well
it could work if you did it really well
or spectacularly well or ultimately well
or something like that you don't know
and you know people have an intonation
of this because one of the things that's
really cool about having a young baby
this is something you don't know until
you have it there's two things you don't
know mmm there's a lot more than two
there's three things you don't know
until you have a baby the one is that
you didn't grow up yet because you
actually don't grow up until someone
else is more important than you you
can't so people think they grow up if
they don't have children but they don't
they just think they do now there are
some people who make sacrifices of other
sorts but this is a whole different ball
of wax as far as I'm concerned it's not
a very elegant metaphor but you learn
that it's kind of relief relief not to
be the center of attention that's cool
that you can sit back because of course
your child in your family and in
societies immediately the center of
attention and so unless you're
narcissistic then you allow that to
happen and then you learn all sorts of
really good things about other people
because other people really like babies
it's so cool I lived in Montreal when we
had our first child and I lived in a
pretty rough neighborhood by Montreal
standards right it's like you know
material has such a great city like
Toronto it's like even the rough
neighborhoods are they're more like
charming with a little you know dark
underbelly something like that but there
were some rough characters in our
neighborhood it was pretty poor and we'd
we'd push her around in her stroller and
he's like grizzled rat dole guys would
come by they'd look at her and they just
light up and they'd come over and like
smile at her and you know you just saw
there the positive element of their
humanity just well forth you ask there s
to be something seriously wrong with you
if you don't respond that way to a baby
you know I mean this is that that's not
good that's not good but it was so cool
to see these people you kind of give
them generally sort of
walk four feet around them on the street
you know and yet they were all of a
sudden all that the layers that were on
them would just fall off and they'd be
so and the babies are sort of like
public property weirdly enough to sort
of like pregnant women you know because
people often treat pregnant women sort
of like they're public property too I
mean in a positive way oh whoa Lord you
would have a baby yeah and you know they
Hey
well they do all sorts of cute things so
so you know the reason I'm telling you
that is because there's a strong impulse
in people to note that there's something
miraculous about the existence of a new
human being and the miraculous element
is all the potential that's there right
that's all there is there is potential
and with every birth there's the
potential for something remarkable to be
introduced in the world and you know one
of the things I've thought too is the
other thing you don't know is that
babies are generic until you have one
and then your baby isn't a generic baby
at all it's like instantly it's a person
with whom you have a relationship that's
closer perhaps than any relationship
that you've ever had and that you can
keep perfect right because most of the
relationships you've had already are
with people who are screwed up in 50
different ways and so are you but here
you've got this baby and like it be care
but it's not rained yet and so you know
you have this possibility of maintaining
this relationship that starts out that
baby really likes you and generally that
continues for quite a long time as there
are two years old you come home they're
really happy to see it's kind of like
having a puppy you know it's like
they're thrilled when you come home it's
like how many people are thrilled when
you come home you know so he'll see you
again it's like no not a little kid a
little kid is thrilled when you come
home and you can keep that going and so
there's this pristine element to the
potential relationship between parents
and children
that's terribly devalued in our society
terribly it's almost as if we're
willfully blind to it and I think it's
an absolute catastrophe because there's
nothing is very little in life that can
compare to
establishing a proper relationship with
with child
they make great company a few if you
keep your relationship with them
Christine and so you know it's
worthwhile you think well I'm so so the
reason I'm telling you this is because
people look at infants and they think
they think this could be the potential
savior of mankind that is what they
think that's how they act so that's what
they think and the thing is it's also
true
now how true it is I don't know
but that's I think probably because I
think it's probably because people don't
dare to find out that's how it looks to
me in Christ's case however as he
sacrifices himself God his father is
simultaneously sacrificing his son it is
for this reason that the Christian
sacrificial drama of son and self is
archetypal nothing greater can be
imagined that's why it's an architect
you can't push past it so that's the
very definition of archetypal that's the
core of what constitutes religious the
greatest of all possible sacrifices is
self and child of that there can be no
doubt pain and suffering define the
world of that equally there can be no
doubt the person who wants to alleviate
suffering who wants to bring about the
best of all possible futures who wants
to create heaven on earth will therefore
sacrifice everything he has to God to
life in the truth so that's a page and a
half from the book I'm going to release
in January
[Applause]
so back to Genesis that were all we
already up to Genesis four and Adam knew
Eve his wife and she conceived and bare
Cain and said I have gotten a man from
the Lord now this is after Adam and Eve
have been chased out of the Garden of
Eden right so what's really cool about
this I really think that the out of the
cain and abel story is the most profound
story i've ever read especially given
that it's you can tell it in 15 seconds
I won't because I tend not to tell
stories in 15 seconds as you may have
noticed but but you can read the whole
thing that quickly and it's so densely
packed that I just can't it's it's
actually unbelievable to me that it can
be that densely packed okay so the first
thing is is that Adam and Eve are not
the first two human beings can enable
are the first two human beings given
Adam and Eve were made by God and they
were born in paradises like what kind of
human beings are those you don't know
any human beings like that human beings
aren't born in Paradise and made by God
human beings are born of other human
beings right and so so that's the first
thing and it's post-fall we're out in
the world world in history now we're not
in some archetypal beyond although we
are still to some degree not to the
degree that was the case with the story
of Adam and Eve we've already been
thrown out of the garden we're already
self-conscious
we're already awake we're already
covered we're already working
we're full-fledged human beings and so
you have the first two human beings can
enable prototypical human beings so
what's cool is that humanity enters
history at the end of the story of Adam
and Eve and then the archetypal patterns
for human behavior are instantaneously
presented it's it's it's absolutely
mind-boggling and it's not a great it's
not a very nice story right so they're
they're brothers they're are hostile
brothers they've got their their their
hands around each other's throat so to
speak or at least that's the case in one
direction so it's a it's a story the
first two human beings
engage in a fratricidal struggle that
ends in the death of the best one of
them that's the story of human beings in
history and that man that doesn't give
you nightmares you didn't understand the
damn story
now in in these hostile brother stories
which are very very common often the
older brother Cain is used and this is
very true in the Bible but it's true in
all sorts of folktales and all sorts of
stories of all sorts for that matter see
the older brother has some advantages
he's the older brother in a agricultural
community the older brother generally
inherited the land not the younger
brothers and the reason for that was is
that well let's say you have like eight
sons and you have enough land to support
a bit of a family and you divide it
among your eight sons then they have
eight sons and they divided among the
eight sons it's like soon everyone has a
little postage stamp that they can stand
on and starve to death on and so that
just doesn't work so you you you you
hand the land down in a piece to the
eldest son and that's just how it is
it's tough luck for the rest of them but
at least they know they're going to have
to go and make their own way it's not
fair but there's no way of making it
fair well so the oldest son has some you
might say he has an additional stake in
the stability and and the stability of
the current hierarchy he has more of a
stake in the status quo so that makes a
more of an emblematic represent
representative of the status quo and
perhaps more likely to be blind in its
favor it's something like that so that
motif creeps up very frequently in the
hostile brothers archetypal struggled so
Cain fits this the story of Cain and
Abel fits this pattern because Cain is
the one who won't budge who won't move
he's stubborn whereas the younger son
who's Abel is often the one who's more
not so much of a revolutionary but
perhaps more of a balance between the
revolutionary and the traditionalist
something like that whereas the older
son tends to be more
traditionalist authoritarian at least in
these metaphorical representations an
Adam knew Eve his wife and she conceived
and bare Cain and said I have gotten a
man from the Lord so there's the first
human being Cain it's like I told you
that the Mesopotamians thought that
mankind was made out of the blood of the
worst demon that the great goddess of
chaos could imagine well the first human
being is a murderer and not only a
murderer a murder of his own brother and
so you know Old Testament that's a hell
of a harsh book and you might think well
maybe that's a little bit too much to
bear and then you might think yeah and
maybe it's true too so that's something
to think about I mean I human beings you
know like they're amazing creatures and
to think about us as a plague on the
planet is its own kind of bloody
catastrophe malevolent low quasi
genocide all metaphor but that doesn't
mean that we're not without our problems
and the fact that this book that sets
sits at the cornerstone of our culture
would present the first man because a
murderer of his brother is something
that should really set you back on your
heels and again she bear his brother
Abel and Abel was a keeper of sheep but
Cain was a tiller of the ground there
you see a very old representation
there's Abel there and he's got his
sheep up on the altar and Cain is
bringing a sheaf of wheat and I don't
know exactly what's happening here with
the blood but or it's a ray perhaps it's
something like that but the overall
impression of the image is that
something transcendent is communicating
with this sacrifice and you can see that
so you think oh how primitive
you know how primitive these people were
sacrificing to their God it's like you
know those people weren't stupid and
this is not primitive
whatever it is it's not permitted it's
sophisticated beyond belief because
the idea as I already pointed out is
that you could sacrifice something of
value and that that would have
transcendent utility and that is by no
means an unsophisticated idea in fact it
might be the great idea that human
beings ever came up with it's an answer
to the problem that's put forward in the
story of Adam and Eve right because we
became self conscious and then we
discovered the future and then we knew
we were going to die and then we knew we
were vulnerable and then we became
ashamed and then we developed the
knowledge of good and evil and then we
got thrown out of paradise is like
that's a big problem so what the hell
are you going to do about it
well sacrifice that's the hypothesis
well that's a hell of a hypothesis man
that's what we're doing you've made
plenty of sacrifices even to sit in this
theater and many people made plenty of
sacrifices to have a theater like this
existed many people made sacrifices so
that we could actually freely engage in
the dialogue that we're engaging in in a
theater like this and so it's like all
of this is built on sacrifice and
sacrifice bloody well better work
because we do not have a better idea
sacrifice what's the counter position
murder and theft so let's go with
sacrifice shall we and perhaps we won't
consider it so damn primitive you know
because it's not so primitive and again
she Barrett his brother Abel and Abel
was a keeper of sheep and Cain was a
tiller of the ground now some people
have read into this the eternal battle
between herdsmen and agriculturalists
it's raged in the American West for
example because the herdsmen like to
have their herds sheep cattle go
wherever they were going to go and of
course they had your cultures the
farmers like to have things fenced off
and so and the agriculturalists actually
won in the final analysis but anyways
Abel is a keeper of sheep and that's
interesting because that makes them a
shepherd and I think that's part of the
critical issue here because a shepherd I
talked a little bit about shepherds
before you know if you look at
Michelangelo's Statue of David which is
another stay
during work I mean that David he's no
trivial figure and of course David who
slays Goliath right and Goliath is like
the giant of the patriarchal enemy it's
something like that and you know Middle
Eastern shepherds they had to keep take
care of sheep and they're edible and the
Lambs are very vulnerable and there were
lots of wild animals around it wasn't
like England in the 16th century it was
like there were lions you know and you
had a slingshot or a stick or some damn
thing and so your job was to keep the
Sheep organized and not let them eat by
the Lions alone and so you had to have a
clue and be tough and self-reliant and
all of those things had to be tough and
self-reliant you had to be able to take
care of a lot of vulnerable things at
build do it on your own and so that's
all built into the Shepherd metaphor and
it's you know it's a tough thing for
it's not a great metaphor for modern
people because we tend to think of the
shepherd is someone like little Lord
Fauntleroy you know like some little
certainly not a lion killing
hyper-masculine lion killing you know
monster that's not a shepherd the
Shepherd sort of dances around and you
know it's not that's not the metaphor
here that's that's that's not the
metaphor here so Abel was a keeper of
sheep but Cain was a tiller of the
ground and in the process of time it
came to pass that Cain brought of the
fruit of the ground an offering unto the
Lord okay so he's participating in the
sacrificial ritual and Abel he brought
of the firstlings of his flock and of
the fat thereof and the Lord had respect
unto Abel and to his offering now you
don't know why that is and this is a
built-in ambiguity I think now I think
there's textual hints but I'm not sure
Abel brought the firstlings of his flock
and of the fat thereof okay so so what
does that mean well he brought high
courts a high quality sacrifice you
don't know that Abel's sacrifice is low
quality because it doesn't say you know
Abel brought God some wilted lettuce and
then burnt it he didn't say that
but but there isn't a sentence there
that talks about how high-quality Cain
sacrifices but in any case the Lord had
respect unto Abel and his offering so
there's a hint that Abel's putting a
little bit more into the whole
sacrificial thing than then Cain but
there's also a hint that maybe God is
just like liking you a little better
than he's like in him and that's I think
useful from a literary perspective
because there is that arbitrariness
about life you know with my own children
for example one of them has had I would
say heat things come easy to him he's
lucky fortunate however you want to put
it he seems to be that sort of person
where's my other child it's like it's
just like one horrible job like
catastrophe after another and it's so
strange to see that because as far as I
can tell there's the character logical
differences are certainly not accounting
for the for the for the difference in
destiny you know my want the one child
who's had so much trouble I mean as a
child was just a wonderful child so
mazing ly happy and easy to long with
and fun and had a terrible time of it so
who knows what God's up to but
distributing fate equally certainly
isn't one of them and the Lord had
respect unto Abel and his offering but
unto Cain and his offering he had not
respect and Cain was very Roth angry
Roth is a tough word you know when these
are translated many times it's hard to
get the full flavor of the words but
Roth and his countenance fell well to
have your countenance fell this is sort
of up to fall is to to have it be heavy
depressed for sure angry for sure
resentful probably Roth that's anger so
Cain is not a happy clam that his hard
work is being rejected by God now that's
worth thinking about really because you
think about how human that story is you
know you're out there well we could say
you might be a useless character and you
know you're whining about how
catastrophic your life is and it's a
pretty much obvious to everyone around
you and you that it's your fault you
just don't try you don't wake up in the
morning you don't get a job you don't
engage in things you're cynical and
you're bitter and you're angry and you
don't try to help the people near you
and you don't try to fix up your own
life and you don't take care of yourself
and you know and then things go wrong
it's like well really what do you expect
but then but that's done I mean that
doesn't mean someone in that situation
will just say well that's okay I deserve
it and they'll be happy about it they
won't they'll be absolutely bitter about
it and angry but you know put that aside
for a moment there are people who seem
to struggle very forthrightly let's say
and still have one catastrophe after
another happened to them and so it's
there's no easy answer in this in this
it's like you can fall fall afoul of God
because your sacrifice is our second
rate or you can just fall a fall of God
and you don't know why well tough luck
for you and then what happens in either
case is exactly this almost inevitably
Cain was rocked in this countenance fell
well you know you meet and I people like
this write to me all the time I've seen
so many many of them as clients you know
they say they're 20 not so often 30 more
commonly sometimes 40 their lives
haven't gone well you know they're in a
pit of despair of one form or another
and not only are they in a pit of
despair but they're extraordinarily
angry about it and god only knows what
they would do with that anger if they
had the opportunity to give it full
voice right you know one of the things
I've always thought about Hitler is that
you know people you have to admire
Hitler that's the thing because he was
an organizational genius you know the
thing that doesn't stop people from
being Hitler the thing people don't
people don't refuse the ambition to
become Hitler because they don't have
the genocide emotive ation they don't
follow that pathway because they don't
have the organizational genius they've
got the damn motivation and you know if
you take a hundred people randomly and
you talk to them and you really talk to
them you'll find that five percent of
them would take their vengeful thoughts
pretty damn far if they were just given
the opportunity and in fact they do
because they make life miserable for
themselves and often for their family
and sometimes for anybody they can come
near and then maybe another twenty
percent of people have that bubble up in
them on a pretty damn regular basis so
you know you can have some sympathy for
Cain if you don't have any sympathy for
Cain then you're not so you can't enable
also they don't just represent to our
contempo types of being they represent
so it's not like you're Cain and you're
able in here Cain
you're able it's like you're
half-and-half and you're half-and-half
and you're half-and-half it's something
like this this is two different
potential patterns of destiny and you
don't manifest one purely and the other
zero it's like you're it's it's like the
line between good and evil that runs
down the human heart it's exactly the
same idea and maybe you're more like
Cain or maybe you're more like Abel but
they're still a little Cain in you no
matter how able you are and maybe more
than a little and probably more than a
litter little and if you watch your
fantasies which I would very much
recommend you'll find that they show you
dark things about you that will shock
you if you allow yourself to be
conscious of what you're thinking so
it's a good time when you're having an
argument with someone especially someone
that you love to just watch the pictures
that flash in the back of your mind
that's part of let's say coming into
contact with what Carl Jung called the
shadow and the shadow is the
manifestation of Cain that's a perfect
way of thinking about it and one of the
things that Jung said about the shadow
because Jung was not someone you mess
around with lightly he said the human
shadow has roots that reach all the way
to hell
and Jung meant that that's no metaphor
for him now he might not have meant it
in the same way that a fundamentalist
Christian from from the southern US
might mean it but I would say that young
men sit in a way that's far more
terrifying and also far more true so and
Cain was very wroth and his countenance
fell
so there's Abel burning is offering away
there and he's in this sort of
relationship with let's call him the
archetypal figure of culture the
archetypal father and it's something he
respects that's the thing it's an
indication that the posture is an
indication of respect and then there's
Cain in the background you see in his
face is in shadow and he's he's jealous
of what's happening here and he's going
through the motions perhaps and maybe
God just doesn't like him we don't know
but he's going through the motions and
he's not very happy about it
and you know that that's actually a
phrase that you could you could carve
into many people's tombstones as an
epitaph for their life
which would be went through the motions
but wasn't very happy about it this is
really an interesting one I think I mean
so I don't know what God is doing here
exactly but he's helping ignite the
sacrificial flame and that's kind of an
interesting idea I think because you
know let's say that you have an impulse
to make a sacrifice you think well I
should change this about my life well
it's like where does that come from that
impulse it's just well just it manifests
itself out of nothing so or you came up
with it well you might want to stop
thinking about that thinking so surely
that you come up with your own thoughts
you don't come up with your damn dreams
do you they just happen
Kanade only knows where they come from
they come from your brain oh boy that's
a sophisticated answer they come from
your unconscious well that's not much
better at least it's somewhat better but
there are those Matan amazing dramas
take place in the theater of your
imagination at night you don't even
understand what they are and yet they
occur night after night and those things
dreams they can contain wisdom it's just
well it just staggers the person who has
the dream once they get the key to the
dream once they remember it's like oh
look you just revealed a bunch of wisdom
to yourself that you didn't know well
where'd that come from well you don't
know how in the world can you dream up
things that you don't know that's a
tough one maybe we'll talk about that at
some point in this lecture series
because there are some reasonable things
that can be said about that but you know
the idea that there's something that's
not you young would call it the self
Karl you would call it the self which he
thought of as the totality of your being
across time and space it's something
like that and that you know each second
that you exist is a slice
manifesting itself across time and space
and he thought of the the self is partly
the voice of conscience whatever that is
that helps guide you when you have to
make a difficult decision and a
difficult decision might be well what do
I need to sacrifice what is how do I
need to discipline myself right what do
I need to forego well how do you figure
those things out well you know this
picture is trying to put forth the idea
that perhaps if you had established the
proper relationship with God the Father
we've talked about what that might mean
then he would help figure out how to get
the sacrificial fires burning so that
you could stay in a proper relationship
with him across time well that's such an
unreasonable proposition it what's the
alternative proposition well this isn't
working out very well that's for sure
you know Kate seems to be doing it I
don't know what it is it's like it's as
if he thinks he can only do it himself
or maybe he wants only to take credit
for it or something like that he's not
in this grateful let's say and inquiring
grateful and inquiring posture because
that's what a perfect posture should be
it should be grateful and inquiring and
grateful is thank God things aren't
worse for me than they are and you
should be grateful about that because
they could be a lot worse than they are
man they can be so bad and inquiring
would be well I don't really know how I
could make it better but I'm open to
suggestions man if I can figure out how
to do it I'll try it
that's the in that's the humility and
the inquiry that's a humble inquiry how
could I make things better it's
something like that and that's like what
sacrifices do I need to make in order to
make things better
that's a good question to ask yourself
you could ask yourself that every
morning what sacrifice do I have to make
to make things better you can decide
what constitutes better how about that
then it's not even as if it's being
imposed on you come up with your own
notion of what constitutes better you
know we try to make it sophisticated
should just be better for you cuz that
isn't going to work very well right you
you're just going to fall downstairs if
you do that because you have to live
with other people and decide stupid
anyways what are you gonna do like can't
even nothing you can even say about that
it's so that that's the doubts the
attitude of a very badly behaved hyper
aggressive two-year-old and I mean that
technically and so you could you could
ask yourself well how I have this day
that lays itself out in front of me what
thing could I let go of that's impeding
my progress that if I let go of would
make my life better my family's life
better my cultures life better my being
better and then that would give you
something to do for the day wouldn't it
and to justify your miserable life
because you need that that's the whole
point of the first story of Adam and Eve
what do you have a miserable life okay
what am I going to do about that well if
you just have a miserable life you're
just going to suffer stupidly and get
bitter about it that's what happens to
cain it's like well how about not doing
that because that seems to just take a
bad deal and make it worse how about
making a sacrifice and seeing if you can
please God and put being on track god
that'd be something to do what could be
better than that what could possibly be
better than that well that's why it's
archetypal man because nothing's better
than that that's where it tops out so
when you can do that you can do that
every day you have to do it a little way
because like what good are you you know
you're not going to go and bring this
socialist utopia into being in one fell
swoop
[Applause]
you might also think that you know one
of the things came might figure out here
there's a couple of things that just
aren't going right for him
downwind of the fire not the right place
to blow from and the fact that he's in
hand velop tin haze and smoke and
breathing it in and the fire isn't
burning might be an indication that he's
doing something wrong or he could be
wiping his eyes and saying Jesus what
kind of stupid bloody universe would
produce smoke like this it's like yes
well that's the more likely outcome and
the Lord said unto Cain why art thou
wroth and why is thy countenance fallen
if thou doest well shalt thou would not
be accepted now that's an interesting
line because and I've looked at a
variety of different translations of
this this seventh verse here like a
bunch of them because the translation
for that that's a critical line and the
translation really matters and so I'll
tell you what I think the story is but
I've been able to figure out and I'm
sure I haven't got it completely right
but it's so he asks the God says to them
if you do well won't you be accepted
what is the hint there right it's
something like well things aren't going
so well for you so the first thing you
might think is you're not doing well
what does that mean you're not doing
good does that not mean you're not
acting properly means it's the hint
because God is suggesting that if you
were doing properly you would be
successful I had a friend at one point
who was a very bitter person and he had
a bunch of problems and some of them
were self-inflicted and some of them
were fate I suppose and he had he had
become very very destructive murderously
destructive genocide ly destructive I
would say you could see it in his dreams
and and he lived with me for a while and
I knew him very well he was a friend of
mine from the time I was 12 until the
time he committed suicide
he was spoke 40 and when he lived with
me I was trying to help him get on his
feet which was why he had come to live
with me
because he thought maybe I could help
him you know on his feet and he could
only take relatively low level jobs you
know like he had some mechanical ability
didn't he didn't get educated although
he's a very very smart person he
probably had an IQ about 135 or
something like that he's very smart and
so he was bitter too because he hadn't
educated himself to the level that his
education select would have demanded so
he had to take jobs that were beneath
him intellectually and he had a really
had that real intellectual arrogance you
know because he was smart and really
smart people often come to believe that
only smart matters and if they're smart
and all that and all that matters is
smart and then the world is sort of
laying itself at their feet then they've
been terribly betrayed and and then they
cling to their intelligence which is
more like a talent or a gift like it's a
like it's an idol you know a false idol
which is exactly what it is in a very
dangerous one and get cynical about the
stupidity of the world and the fact that
their talents weren't properly
recognized and that's just not that
helpful you know because smart is a good
thing but I'll tell you if you don't use
it properly it will devour you just like
all arbitrarily assigned talent right so
you might have a talent but it's your
friend if you use it properly and if you
excuse it it will be your enemy and
maybe that's how God keeps the cosmic
scales adjusted but anyhow my friend was
a very smart person although not as
smart as he thought he was unfortunately
and and but he hadn't done what would
have been necessary with that
intelligence to make it manifest itself
properly in the world and that also
embittered him because he also knew that
there was more that he could have done
if he would have done it and perhaps
more that he could still do what I was
suggesting to him while he was living
with us because he was you know two
levels from homeless by that point was
that he should find a job that he could
find working in a in a garage working in
a shop something like that cuz he had
some mechanical ability and that he
should do he should separate himself
from the arrogance that made him presume
that such a job would
beneath him because at that point no job
was beneath him and but more importantly
it's not so obvious that jobs are
beneath people you know because even if
you're a even if the imagine you have a
job as a checkout person in a in a
grocery store you know it's a fairly
unskilled job you can be in some
miserable resentful horrid bastard doing
that job boy you know you can come in
there just exuding resentment bitterness
and making fakes and making sure that
every customer that passes by you has a
slightly worse day than they need to
right and and you know pilfering time
and perhaps pilfering goods and being
resentful about the people who who gave
you the position because they're above
you in the dominance hierarchy and
talking you know bad things gossiping
behind the back of your co-workers it's
like you can take your menial position
self-described and turn that into a very
nice little slice of hell that's for
sure and you know you go into places
like that I always think of the
archetypal diner in that way you know
you guys have been in this diner there's
a really good opposite diner and there's
a great video on YouTube it's Tom Waits
reading reading a poem by Bukowski and I
think it's called Nirvana and it's about
a good diner that he happened to visit
Bukowski happened to visit when he was
on a bus when he was a when he was a kid
a diner where everything was going well
and you could listen to that it's great
I think it's great but this is the
opposite diner I'm thinking wow so you
go into a diner right it's seven o'clock
in the morning and you order some bacon
and eggs and some toast and then you
look around in the diner and you think
it was like 1975 when the windows were
last washed and there's this kind of
thick coating of who gives a damn grease
on the on the walls you know and and the
floor too has got that sort of
stickiness that you really have to work
out to develop over years you know and
the waitress is she's not happy to be
there and the guy behind the counter
isn't happy that that happens to be the
waitress that he's working with and then
you know you walk down the stairs maybe
to the washroom and that's its own
little trip
so you come back and you order your damn
eggs and you order your toast in the
order your bacon and then it comes and
like the eggs are too cooked on the
bottom so they're kind of brown and then
they're kind of raw on top and and
they're cold in the middle which is you
really have to work the cooking egg like
that man but you can master that with
like ten years of bitterness you teach
how to cook an egg like that and then
the toast here's what you do with the
toast right you put you take you take
the white bread you know the pre sliced
stuff that no one should ever eat then
you put that in the toaster and you
overcook it and then you wait and then
you pop it out of the toaster and then
because it's overcooked you scrape it
off and you knock off the crumb so it
doesn't look too burnt and then you wait
till it's cold and then you put cold
margarine on it because if you put cold
first of all not butter but if you put
cold margarine or you can also kind of
tear holes in it so that then it has
lumps of margarine in it and it's really
dry except where it's too greasy so
that's like your own little work of art
man and then you put that on the side
with the with the-- with the eggs and
then you have the potatoes and this is
how you cook the potatoes properly you
know so they're leftover potatoes and
you keep dumping new leftover potatoes
into the old leftover potatoes over
weeks and so some of the potatoes have
they're no longer potatoes right they've
have returned to mother earth huh then
you flop them on the grill and you sort
of hide it oh you burn them a bit I
guess and then you've slapped them on
the plate and Jesus you don't eat those
man that's for sure and that's the point
and then you have the bacon and you want
to make sure you buy the lowest possible
quality bacon not such let's how you
start and then you throw it on the grill
and you don't your grill has to be
overheated to do this you have to cook
the bacon so that it's raw in places and
burnt in other places and it has that
delightful picked like odor that only
really cheap badly cooked bacon can
provide or may
we use those little breakfast sausages
that no one in their bloody right mind
would let within 15 feet of anything
living you know and then you serve that
right and you serve it with the kind of
orange juice that is only orange in
color and then with coffee that's ah
what would you say it was started too
early in the morning that's the first
thing bad quality coffee started too
early in the morning got cold once or
twice and has been reheated and then you
serve that with whitener like here's
your breakfast it's like no man that's
not breakfast that's hell
no and and you created it and then what
you do if you have a diner like that is
because you have a miserable life if you
have a diner like that and you've really
worked on achieving that is every night
you go home and you curse your wife and
you curse your kids and you well
cursed God too for producing a universe
where a diner like yours is allowed to
exist and that's your bloody life so
also that's what God is trying to point
out here is
if thou doest well shalt thou not be
accepted and if thou doest not well then
sin lies at your door well so what I
looked at lots of translations for this
and actually the next line is and unto
these unto thee shall be his desire yes
what God actually says is something like
this is like you know things aren't
going so well for you but if you were
behaving properly they would but instead
this is what you've done sin came to
your door and sin means to you know pull
your arrow back and to miss the target
sin came to your door but he uses a
metaphor and the metaphor is something
like sin came to your door like this
sexually aroused cat predator thing and
you invited it in first and then you let
it have its way with you it's like you
entered into a creative uses of sexual
metaphor he entered into a creative
exchange with it and gave birth to
something as a consequence and that what
you gave birth to you that that's your
life and and you knew it you're self
conscious after all you knew you were
doing this and you conspired with this
thing to produce the situation that
you're in
young said something about this similar
about the eatable mother situation sorry
it was very politically incorrect what
he said of course every single thing he
wrote was politically incorrect so just
how you could tell he was a thinker by
the way he talked about the unholy
alliance between hyper dependent
children and their mothers and he said
well it's actually because you probably
thought about it as a as a maternal
thing
I'm not putting Freud down because Freud
mapped out the oedipal situation
brilliantly
I'm not putting 4i down but you know
Jung was taking the ideas and expanding
them outward and you know he said that
there was an actually an unholy alliance
between a hyper dependent child and a
and they need to pull over dependent
mother and the Alliance was the mother
would always offer so maybe the kid is
supposed to go off and do something that
would require a little bit of courage
and effort and the mother says well are
you sure you're feeling well enough to
do it and then the child could say yes
or the child could say no and then you
know be put in bed and maybe didn't all
of that and but the thing is the child
made the damn decision too and you might
think well that's pretty harsh but just
because children are little doesn't mean
they're stupid and you don't know
children if you don't know how children
know how to manipulate because they are
staggeringly good at that because
they're studying you non-stop trying to
figure out what you're up to and be how
they can get what they want in the way
that they wanted and so they can play a
manipulative game no problem especially
if they're well schooled in it and so
it's sort of like that it's like maybe
the mother is a little too a little
timid and a little inclined to
overprotect and maybe the child is a
little manipulative and a little willing
to not take that courageous step out in
the world and to regress into infantile
dependency instead and then you get a
terrible dynamic building across time
that is like a vicious circle you know
or like a positive feedback loop that
just expands and expands and expands
because sometimes in families you see a
hyper dependent child and a perfectly
independent child in same mother
so obviously same there I mean mother's
very complex and mother for child a and
mother for child B are not the same
mother even if they happen to be the
same human being that literature is
quite clear on that but you get my point
but God's idea was not only are you not
doing well because you're not doing well
but you're not doing well because you've
actually really spent a lot of work
figuring out how to not do well this is
like creative effort on your part and if
you read about truly malevolent people
and you could start with the Columbine
killers because they left some very
interesting Diaries behind so I would
recommend them if you there
plenty of serial killers you could read
about in the people who've really gone
out and done dark things and I've read
more than my fair share of that sort of
thing and understand it quite well if
you really want to have your countenance
fall and be Roth ten years of brooding
on your own catastrophe sort of a loan
and letting your fantasies take shape
and endi and egging them on and and
allowing them to flourish and let's say
take possession of you because that's
exactly the right way to think of it
that will get you somewhere like this
and there are more people who are like
that than you think and you're more like
that than you think
well so Kayne he's obviously not very
happy about this whole answer obviously
because the last thing you want to hear
if your life is turned into a
catastrophe and you take God to task for
creating a universe where that sort of
thing was allowed is that it's your own
damn fault and you should straighten up
and fly right so to speak and you
shouldn't be complaining about the
nature of being but that is the answer
he gets and so then what happens well we
have to infer that if Kane was angry
before that he's a lot more angry now
and of course that's exactly what the
story reveals and Cain talked with Abel
his brother and it came to pass when
they were in the field that Cain rose up
against Abel his brother and slew him
I'm going to read you something else now
this is foreshadowing again this is from
the same chapter by the way do what is
meaningful not what is expedient Jesus
was led into the wilderness according to
the story to be tempted by the devil
Matthew 4:1 prior to his crucifixion
this is the story of Cain restated
abstractly Cain is far from happy as we
have seen he's working hard or so he
thinks but God is not pleased meanwhile
Abel is dancing away in the daisies his
crops flourish women love him first of
all he's a pretty good guy everyone
oh is it he deserves his good fortune
all the more reason to hate him I used
to joke when I used to teach at Harvard
and now and then my wife would have some
of the undergraduates over we used to
joke afterwards because some of them
were many of them were very remarkable
kids you know like they they were super
smart they were athletic or they had
some dramatic ability or they were
musicians or they done some spectacular
charitable work because he basically to
get accepted into Harvard you had to be
top of your damn school and then you had
to have at least two other outstanding
things going for you you know and what
was so annoying about most of these kids
this was our joke with you really both
liked them and respected them it's like
we my joke was do you think they would
have had the good graces to be like
dislikeable sons of at least
with all the all those other great
things going for them they had to act
like respectability and like ability to
it as well so you thought well you know
it really couldn't happen to a better
person it's like good god well that's
that's that's able situation you know
it's like and you know the funny thing
too is that that's an ideal that's the
ideal right because an ideal person
let's say would be someone who you would
want to be like and and someone who is
operating in the world like you would
want to operate and someone whom fortune
was smiling on and someone who is making
the right sacrifices it's really what
you would want to be and so can kill
that right so it's a psychological story
too and you see this in the cynicism
that people have about people who have
done well in the world they're always
looking for some reason why they've done
well they must be crooked or they must
be they must be conniving or they must
be arrogant or they must be psychopathic
or you know and of course all of those
things exist but it's a very bad trick
to play on yourself to make the
proposition that the person in the world
who represents your own ideal is that
ideal because of despicable reasons
because what you do is train yourself
that the ideal that you should pursue
can only exist if it's motivated by
despicable reasons and then what not
only is able your brother dad as your
brother
in the field in reality but you've also
slaughtered your own ideal well then
what the hell are you going to work for
well how are you gonna live then well
bitterly and miserably that's for sure
bitterly miserably and hopelessly that's
how you're going to live you know it's
so rare that I see especially publicly
that people honestly admit with sports
figures they'll do it that's that's one
place where that seems to happen but
it's so uncommon for expressions of
admiration and gratitude to manifest
themselves in any public communication
of any sort newspapers TV YouTube
Twitter it's almost always undermining
and backbiting and criticism and very
often directed to people who who have
often done little else but bring good
things into the world for other people
and that's part of why this is such a
profound story he's a pretty good guy
everyone knows that he deserves his good
fortune all the more reason to hate him
that's for sure
Kane broods on his misfortune like a
vulture on an egg he enters the desert
wilderness of his own mind he obsesses
over his ill fortune and betrayal he
nourishes his resentment he indulges in
ever more elaborate fantasies of revenge
his arrogance grows to Luciferian
proportions I'm ill used and oppressed
he thinks this is a stupid bloody planet
it can go to hell and with that he
encounters Satan in the wilderness and
falls prey to his temptations and he
does what he can in john milton's
unforgettable words to confound the race
of mankind in the first route and mingle
and involve earth with hell done all
despite the Great Creator he turns to
evil
to obtain what good forbade him and he
does it voluntarily self consciously and
with MELAS let him who has ears here so
that's the first two human beings the
resentful bitter failure taking an axe
to the admirable success then the Lord
said unto Cain where is Abel thy brother
and he said I know not am I my brother's
keeper
and he said what hast thou done the
voice of thy brother's blood crieth unto
me from the ground now art thou cursed
from the earth which hath opened her
mouth to receive thy brother's blood
from thy hand you know if you want to
understand that which I would recommend
you could read Dostoyevsky's crime and
punishment that's a great it's a great
novel I think it might be the greatest
novel ever written because I haven't
read every novel but in my experience
it's the greatest novel and it is
exactly this it it says what happens
psychologically if you commit the
ultimate crime it's amazing it's
absolutely amazing it's it's it's
there's there's no psychologist like
Dostoyevsky we now tell us the ground it
shall not henceforth yield unto thee her
strength a fugitive and a vagabond shalt
thou be in the earth and Cain said unto
the Lord my punishment is greater than I
can bear
now one of the things that's interesting
about this is that you know it
I think the punishment that God lays on
Cain is it's like the inevitable
consequences of Cain's action it's
something like that it's like well he
killed his brother there's no going back
from that man like good luck forgiving
yourself for that especially if he was
an ideal especially if he was your ideal
because he haven't just killed your
brother and of course
tortured your parents and the rest of
your family you've deprived the
community of someone who is upstanding
and you did it for the worst possible
motivations it's like there's no up from
there right that's that's as close to
hell as you could manage on earth I
would say and Kane said unto the Lord my
punishment is greater than I can bear
behold thou hast driven me out this day
from the face of the earth and from thy
face shall I be hid doubt to is like
there's also no turning back to God
let's say after an error like that
because well you've done everything you
possibly could to spite God assuming he
exists and the probability that you're
going to be able to mend that
relationship in your now broken state
when you couldn't mend it to begin with
before you did something so terrible
starts to move towards zero and it shall
come to pass that everyone that findeth
me shall slay me and the Lord said unto
him there for whosoever slayeth Cain
vengeance shall be taken on him
Sevenfold and the Lord said a mark upon
Cain lest any finding him should kill
him that's an interesting thing I wanted
about that for a long time because you
might think well why would God take Cain
under his wing so to speak given what's
already happened and I think it has
something to do with the emergence of
the idea that it was necessary to
prevent tit-for-tat
revenge slayings it's something like
that you know and and there's hints of
that later in the text because you know
it's like well I kill your brother and
then you kill two of my brothers and
then I kill your whole family and then
you kill my whole town and then I kill
your whole country and then we blow up
the world it's like yeah that's probably
not a very intelligent solution to the
initial problem even though the initial
problem which might be a murder is not
an easy thing to solve but I think it's
something like that and then the last
part of the story is God's William Blake
so
Adam and Eve have discovered their dead
son and Cain has become cognizant I
would say of what he did and what he is
right so it's another entrance into a
form of self-consciousness it's it's you
know the self-consciousness that Adam
and Eve developed was painful enough
they become aware of their own
vulnerability in their nakedness and
perhaps even their capacity for evil but
Cain becomes aware of his voluntary
engagement with evil itself and sees
that as a crucial human capability and
that's something modern people you know
it's no wonder we don't take it
seriously like I know in the Academy and
among intellectual circles for decades
the idea of evil has been it's like what
are you medieval or something you know
the whole idea of evil you don't that's
a non-starter as an intellectual
starting place as a as a topic and
that's something that I've just been
unable to understand because I cannot
understand how you could possibly have
more than a cursory knowledge of the
history of the 20th century much much
less a deep knowledge of the history of
the 20th century and to walk away with
any other conclusion then well good
might not exist but evil hey the
evidence for that is so overwhelming
that that only willful blindness could
possibly explain denying in its
existence
and that was actually a useful discovery
for me because I also concluded perhaps
that if it was true evil existed then it
it was true by inference that its
opposite existed because the opposite of
evil let's say the evil of the
concentration camp let's say or we could
get more specific about it we could say
there's this one thing that used to
happen in our switz where they would
take
people off the incoming trains those who
lived you know that weren't stacked
around the outside of the train train
cars and you know froze to death because
it was too cold you know those who only
had to be stuck in the middle where it
was warm enough so that maybe the old
people died because they suffocated but
at least some of them were alive when
they made it to our sweats and then they
took those poor people out one of the
tricks that the guards used to play on
them was to have the the newly arrived
prisoners hoist like hundred pound sacks
of wet salt and carried them from one
side of the compound and these compounds
were big this was a city it wasn't like
a gymnasium it was like a city there
were tens of thousands of people there
they'd have them carry the sack of wet
salt from one side of the compound to
the other and then back right and that
was to make a mockery out of the notion
that work would set you free it's like
no no you work here but there's nothing
productive about it the whole point it's
exactly the opposite of sacrifice in
some sense it's oh we're going to make
you act out working but all it will do
is speed your demise and maybe we can
decorate it up a little bit because not
only will it speed up your demise it
will do it in a very painful way while
simultaneously increasing the
probability that other people's demises
will be painful and sped up it's a work
of arts that's for sure and to to know
about that sort of thing and not to not
regard it as evil means well you can
figure out what it means for yourself
and Cain went out from the presence of
the Lord and dwelt in the Land of Nod on
the East of Eden and Cain knew his wife
and she conceived you know and one of
the critics the criticisms are fairly
common criticism of these biblical
stories is well if Cain and Abel were
the only two people and from Adam and
Eve it's like where did all these other
people come from and doesn't that make
the story like simple-minded it's like
no that makes the reader simple-minded
you know I mean really that's the best
criticism of this you're going to come
up with I mean absolutely
missed the point that that would be the
right response you missed the point and
Cain knew his wife and she conceived and
bare Enoch and he builded the city and
so it's Cain that builds the cities and
starts the civilization and called
that's pretty rough too right so it's
the first fratricidal murderer who
builds the cities after the name of his
son Enoch and unto Enoch was born around
etc etc going through the generations
and Lamech took unto Him two wives the
name of the one without on the name of
the other Zillah this is a an attempt to
flesh out the genealogy and to describe
how culture started in some sense in
these tribal communities and ADA bear
jebel and he was the father of such as
dwell in tents and of such as have
cattle and his brother's name was Jubal
and he was the father of all such handle
the harp and organ and Zilla she also
bear tubal-cain an instructor of error
every artificer in brass and iron
tubal-cain
traditionally is the first person who
makes weapons of war and Lamech back to
Lamech a descendant of Cain said unto
his wives Adah and Zillah hear my voice
he wise of Lamech hearken unto my speech
for I have slain a man to my wounding
and a young man to my hurt if Cain be
Avenged Sevenfold truly Lamech seventy
and Sevenfold well what I see and that
is this proclivity of this murderous
capacity of Cain as it manifests itself
as society develops to to a murderous
intent that transcends the mirror
killing of a brother you hurt me I hurt
you back no you heard me I kill you in
six other people and the thing that
happens after that is to not make it
seven people but to make it seventy
people and so there's this idea that
once that that first murderous seed is
sown it has this proclivity to manifest
itself exponentially and that's a
warning and that's also why I think
tubal Cain who's one of Cain's
descendants was the first person who
made weapons of war and that's pretty
much the story of Cain and Abel and it's
a hell of a story as far as I can tell
and I think it's worth thinking about
pretty much forever because there's so
many so many it has so many facets you
know and I think the most usefully
revealing of those facets is the the
potential for the story once understood
to shed light on not your own failure
not even on your rejection by being
let's say but by the but on the
proclivity to murder the best and the
best in you for revenge upon that
violation because what that means and we
know that knowledge of good and evil
into the world so to speak with Adam and
Eve's transgression is that now not only
does humanity have to contend with
tragedy and suffering and even the
unharvested fruits of proper sacrifice
but with the introduction of real
malevolence into the world so there's
the fall into history and then there's
the discovery of sacrifice as a
medication for the fall and then there's
a counter position which is the
emergence of malevolence as the enemy of
proper sacrifice and that's where we're
left at the end of Cain and Abel and
that's the end of that lecture thank
[Applause]
alright ok so you said that one of your
moral axioms is that pain is bad and so
we should work to eliminate unnecessary
suffering isn't this the basis for a
secular morality like utilitarianism and
can we therefore be moral without
religion
well I don't think that its first of all
probably to the first question but
that's also that derivation is
predicated on the idea that that's the
only idea you know that I'm putting
forward as a ethical idea and it's not
if that was the only idea well then you
could derive from that a fairly
straightforward brand of utility
utilitarianism but that also I think to
push the argument in that direction also
necessitates the reduction of what might
constitute pain to something to
uni-dimensional because I think
suffering is better term than pain
although pain in some sense is at the
core of suffering suffering is a
multi-dimensional phenomena and I don't
think that you can draw a simple
utilitarian argument from that either
the existence of suffering or the
observation that it's the reduction of
unnecessary suffering might be a good
thing
so I'm also leery of those see it's not
reasonable in some sense to reduce a
complex set of ideas to a single
proposition and then say the ideas that
I've been putting forward and then to
reduce another complex philosophical set
of ideas to a single proposition and
then say aren't those two things the
same and they are to reduce them to the
two simple axioms or you could argue
that they're the same but but you but I
would say there's a tremendous amount
left out in the telling and that what's
left out is relevant it kind of reminds
me of those those philosophical games
that psychologists often play it's like
well if there was I think when I what's
the one I don't know if I can recall
this properly
it's the trolley cart problem
something like you know if there was a
train that was out of control and it was
going towards six people on one track
when you flip a switch so it's switched
tracks and only killed one person would
you do that
and I read a question like that I think
that's a stupid question and the reason
I think that is because you can't take a
situation like that and render it
properly by reducing it to that question
and then you also can't assume that the
person who answers that question would
in fact act in the way they answered you
can't presume any of that it's like
because in a situation like that in a
high-stress situation like that the
devil is in the details and I've dealt
with situations like that a number of
times and know perfectly well that the
Devils in the detail so I think that
there's a there's an intellectual
reduction to make a philosophical point
that doesn't give the complexity of the
topic justice and then there's a second
part to that which was and therefore
can't we be moral without religion well
I would say that question also suffers
in some sense from the same problem of
formulation I I'm very hesitant ever to
answer a question of the form is a
merely a manifestation of B when a and B
are very complex things because the
answer that is it depends on what you
mean by moral and what you mean by
religious because you see there's an
underlying intellectual maneuver in in a
question like that and the underlying
maneuver is the a priori assumption that
something as complex as religion or as
complex as morality can be reduced to an
object with a name and that then two
objects reduced to the name can be
assessed simultaneously and I don't
think that that's the case I think you
can say something like
is a triangle a square I think you can
say that but I don't think you can say
is it possible to have morality without
religion I don't think you can have that
question because it it has to be
expanded out so it's like what do you
mean by morality exactly and what do you
mean by religion because maybe and maybe
not
and so and so the answer to that
question is to decompose the question I
[Applause]
don't want my young children
indoctrinated with dangerous ideas and
as time marches on I trust public
education less and less I know that you
have strong thoughts on the danger of
the devouring oedipal mother who harms
your child by protecting them and that's
certainly not what I aspire to I wonder
if in spite of your idea that kids need
to become tough and learn to slay
dragons if you have anything good to say
about the idea of homeschooling well I
don't have anything bad to say about it
I do know that the Quebec government has
recently taken moves to make it much
more difficult for people to homeschool
their children and it's not like five
years I mean 15 years ago I would have
presumed that the vast majority of
people who were homeschooling their
children were to be viewed with
skepticism initially I'm not so sure
about that anymore
you know for example I was sent a poster
today someone sent me this link that
they found in the local junior high
school and one of the media pieces that
were recommended on this poster was a
movie called Hedwig and the Angry Inch
now I thought that was a terrible movie
even though I'm perfectly capable of
enjoying bizarre movies but
so it's a bizarre movie that's for sure
but I also thought it was a terrible
bitter movie terrible and bitter those
are separate a movie can be bitter and
be quite great but it was a terrible
movie and it was a bitter movie but I
can tell you one bloody thing about that
movie it's not required viewing for
twelve-year-old kids that's for sure so
I think you have increasing reason to be
skeptical of the public education system
I also looked at the Elementary Teachers
Federation of Ontario's guidelines for
education from kindergarten to grade 8
and what that is in essence and I think
I will do a video about it in the
relatively near future is a blueprint
for transforming children into social
justice warriors it basically says that
it's like you don't have to be a
conspiracy theory to read that I mean we
have social justice tribunals in Ontario
and so the idea is well if you're going
to get your children if you're going to
get people to what would you say favor
equity properly well then you better
start teaching them well they're young
it's like maybe not so now you you ask
that question properly because you say
well the terrible education system the
wonderful mother homeschooling right
that's the danger it's like no because
it might not be the wonderful mother
homeschooling it might be the
pathological mother using the pathology
of the education system as a excuse to
get her talons into her children right
because that's certainly equally
possible or perhaps even more possible
because at least in the public education
system there's some necessity for
consensus so to have something that you
have to be very aware of and work to
prevent right and so I would say if
you're going to do that probably best
not to do it on your own and you need
it's like you need a Board of Advisors
or something like that and so maybe it
can't just be you and you have to figure
out well what what is the aim and how
are you going to manage that and what
makes you think you can do it even if
it's being done badly publicly what
makes you think you could do it better I
mean my general advice is and people
have asked me this in fact I had a
conversation with the guy who was Tyler
my backyard this morning about something
his son had said to him that he was
taught at school recently which really
made the Tyler who had come from a
rather authoritarian country step back
on his heels and think I'm not so sure I
should be sending my kid to public
school anymore and maybe I shouldn't be
living in Toronto even you know but my
general advice is keep an eye on your
kids and discuss with them what they're
learning and and help equip them with
the tools to not only to articulate
their own viewpoint in response to what
they're being taught now if the problem
is you might not have the time nor the
ability to do that that's no simple
thing and increasingly if you're
unwilling to have your children
participate in what is increasingly
indoctrination and not education thanks
to in no small part to the Ontario
Institute of Studies on education which
is an institution that I particularly
despise because I think that all it does
is almost all it does now is produce
indoctrinate errs of children it's not
an easy it's not an easily easy problem
to solve so more more power to you
wanting to put your children in a
situation where they're not being
indoctrinated but the alternative is
very very complicated and difficult so
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
likely you know I would say generally
speaking there's a shamanic basis to to
almost all the religious traditions
because that's the milieu out of which
the religious traditions emerge now I
can't say much more than that because I
don't know and no one does that
the particularity mean you might say
well is there an allusion to the
ingestion of psychoactive chemicals in
the Adam and Eve story and people have
made that case and there's been powerful
cases made so there's a book for example
I think it's called soma by a guy named
Gordon Wausau who was the first person
an amateur mycologist who was the first
person to propose that the soma of the
Hindus was we're at Amanita muscaria
mushrooms which is actually a those are
the the red mushrooms with the white
dots that you always see on fairytales
you know the cute ones
toadstools flies like to eat them
they're called fly agaric also and why
seem to like getting stoned I know
that's weird
I know that's weird thing to say but
there's I have a good book on animal use
of psychedelics and more animals use
them than you might think but anyways
there is some evidence that you know of
use of of the injecting of fruits let's
say metaphorically speaking as an aid to
the transformation of consciousness that
goes back so far that well forever as
far as human beings are concerned but to
specifically tie that to the Adam and
Eve story I haven't been able to see any
evidence that would definitely link them
you know there's there's been a lot of
interesting books written about that
there's one that was quite a kind of a
weird hit and I think in the early late
60s might have been early 70s sort of
got brushed off as a hippie book but it
really wasn't it's called the sacred
mushroom in the cross absolutely that's
the sort of book you read you think huh
I don't know
what to do about that I have no idea
what to do about that look so that's all
I can say about that yep my questions
about martyrdom so um what do you think
martyrdom or the willingness to suffer
and die for what you believe if anything
says of the conviction and what do you
think is the benefit for the martyr
which is at least traditionally
immaterial and transcendent good
compared to the regular sacrifice or
practical sacrifice which is ordered to
the Future material psychological or
economic good man you guys really come
up with some wicked questions I think it
depends to some degree on how you define
martyrdom you know because you could you
could define it as the tendency to
pathologically self aggrandizing self on
public display or you could say it's the
decision to be immovable about a set of
principles right so let's go with that
one forget about the first one well I
wouldn't recommend it to anyone right in
some sense it's it's
that's a really tough one people ask me
I'll make it personal I suppose people
asked me when I first got involved in
saw this political controversy back in
September October well they asked me a
couple of things they they asked me if
this was the hill that I really would
choose to die on us like pronouns and
the transgender issue yeah well it's not
what about one I would have picked and
but I mean it was about language you
know and that that makes it non-trivial
I mean bill C 16 was passed this week as
you know and one of the things that was
quite interesting about that I will
answer your question was that brenda
Cosman who was the woman that I debated
I think it's one of the persons that I
debated didn't like to be referred to as
a woman but I don't didn't think it was
Brenda anyways she wrote an op-ed and I
believe it was in The Globe and Mail but
it might have been the National Post
saying as I knew she would say that bill
C 16 was just the beginning that we have
plenty of work left to do and yes you
can bloody well be sure that we have
plenty of work left to do anyways I was
asked during that period of time whether
or not I was being a martyr you know and
I thought well it's not really one of my
ambitions you know it's like that's sort
of torn to the Lions thing doesn't sound
like exactly something you might aim for
but I think well sometimes you find out
in your life maybe that there's
something you won't do and one thing and
then maybe you just don't do it no
matter what the consequence is maybe I
don't know because you know I haven't
been pushed to that point but there have
been people who have been pushed to that
point in history and they basically said
I don't care what you do to me I'm not
doing that
and you know maybe some of them were
suicidal and some of them were psychotic
and some of them had whatever other
problems that people might have but yeah
I do have this suspicion now and then
that some of them were just kind of
serious about and saying no and there's
some utility in being serious about
saying no and it that sort of revealed
itself to me I suppose to some degree
back in September we
and I read a piece of legislation that
said I would have to use some words that
were legislated by the government and I
thought there's no goddamn way I'm going
to do that under any conditions that I
can imagine now there are conditions and
I have a pretty good imagination for
unimaginable conditions I couldn't see
it because I thought that if I did that
I would break through whatever would be
left of me after having done that would
no longer be me and I'm not interested
in that I know what that would be like I
actually do know what that would be like
and I'm not interested in that I would
rather have whatever else happens happen
and people have said to me well you're
so courageous for taking this stand it's
like yeah well I'm not going to claim
any sort of other world courage I can
tell you that but I can tell but one
thing I do know the difference between
these different forms of hell let's put
it that way
and there's the hell that maybe I might
be dragged through if I don't agree
don't act in accordance with this law
and there's the hell that I would be
dragged through if I did act in
accordance with the law and I would
vastly prefer the first hell to the
second and isn't clear to me that that
actually constitutes courage is it
useful because that's also the question
about martyrdom I think it's very useful
for people to see that someone will say
there's no way there's no conceivable
way that you can get me to do that and
and I've thought long and hard about
such things too because i've taught very
many people to negotiate and one of the
things I always teach them is you don't
negotiate from a position of weakness
because you lose and so if I say no to
something and I mean no I mean no I
bloody well won't do it and I think that
if there are people who also agree that
such things aren't appropriate to have
the example of someone who says no and
means it actually turns out to be useful
and so then I would say well that's an
inclination in the potential direction
of martyrdom and but I don't see how to
distinguish
that that from actually just having the
courage of your convictions and so
sometimes you might say well a person
who has sufficient courage in their
convictions will sometimes be put to
death
well if that's the definition of a
martyr then sometimes but not all of all
ways that's a really good thing and one
of the things I really liked about
Solzhenitsyn's book The Gulag
Archipelago which is an I refer to it
often it's an absolutely staggering book
is that he put in many many stories of
people who were in the gulag and they
were often religious believers which was
a shock to him because he was an
atheistic communist when when he first
entered the camp's they were often
religious believers and they were people
who said no there were things they would
not do they would not participate in
what the regime was asking them to do
and he you have to read it because the
Devils in the stories write the details
in the stories but Solzhenitsyn in the
camps grew to have tremendous admiration
for such people and actually viewed them
as exemplars of the mode of being that
was necessary for him to escape both the
communist propaganda that had shaped him
as an individual and also the terrible
bitterness and sorrow and anger that he
experienced as a consequence of being
flung into the terrible concentration
camp conditions of the gulag archipelago
so yep
hey Doc thanks for staying alive and
potentially saving humanity yeah that's
good stuff
I'm wondering about a couple of things
firstly who won that childhood fight you
kind of let that let that just slide so
I'm thinking it's a big L well I can
tell you because he was a tough little
kid see I don't remember what happened
but my remembrance of him was that he
could eat pound meal pretty pretty
effectively so yeah yeah his name was
Vernon switchin ik yeah he was really
the good friend of mine and and I think
I think Vernon still lives in Fairview
so if if he hears of this then maybe
he'll remember that too and and know you
know so probably he would have won I
didn't win that many physical fights
when I was a kid so that's not the only
question okay anyway cool
I'm not sure if you if you've actually
been asked us before I've missed the
last two lectures but I wondering what
your thoughts are on polkan jr. Tolkien
and his work not just Lord of the Rings
but the similar alien which is basically
like I'm seeing all this and I'm
thinking it's like the modern Bible in a
way it's got the weird names like to
Paul Cain and all that stuff and and
specifically when we were talking about
Cain just now and how he was thing just
moving and he was talking about how he
felt like betrayed by God and you any
misspent his whole life working it to
spite him essentially and he kind of set
the path for for the darkness in
humanity yeah that's almost exactly
Melkor which was in the similar alien
basically what's what spawned everything
evil in Middle Earth and Mordor and
whatnot and I don't even know I won't be
welcome talking with a student of
mythology and you know the the the the
story of The Hobbit is a retelling of
Beowulf in large part and that's a
dragon slaying myth and and so the the
the reason the Tolkien and rolling for
that
are so popular is because they've done a
very good job of making the old myths
new and and well look what's happened
with the Marvel series it's the same
thing and with Star Wars and all of that
is that you can't not respond to these
stories now you're going to find them in
one form or another and sometimes well
with the biblical stories for example
the mythological the meaning of the
mythological content has become
invisible that's partly the death of God
that Nietzsche was referring to but that
doesn't mean that the stories themselves
vanish because people have an eternal
hunger for them now the problem with
them emerging in let's say more literary
or less sophisticated form let's take
the Marvel movies as an example is that
they're not surrounded by an articulated
culture the same way the biblical
stories are so for example they're not
surrounded by something like Paradise
Lost by John Milton which or or Dante's
Inferno which are works of unlimited
depth and so you throw away something of
great value and reacquire it in a
different place with less value perhaps
but more comprehensibility it's not it's
not a great trade that is not a critique
of Tolkien it's not a critique of
anybody who's drawing on mythological
stories for their narratives you have to
do that to be a good storyteller but
it's nice to go as close to the source
as you can as well so yeah and the
overlaps that you described well yeah
it's exactly what you'd expect because
if you deal with great mythological
themes you start to get the archetypes
are at the bottom of stories and so if
the story goes down far enough it runs
into the archetypes and that well that
was Jung's claim and I think he got that
exactly right
so
last one there's a passage in Paradise
Lost where the demons are building
pandemonium under Mammon's sort of
guidance and they crack open the it's
not really earth but hell and they take
out the gold and they build pandemonium
which is the most sophisticated
architectural wonder of all time in
Milton's language and and this this
conception of taking material and
turning it into a temple to oneself was
interpreted by Humphrey Jennings who was
the founder of the mass observation
movement if anyone saw the opening to
the britons
2012 games the history of the Industrial
Revolution he said was encapsulated by
this passage in Milton where you have
demons building a temple for themselves
out of matter and that mankind in
Milton's language was was taught to do
this or that they learned it first by
this example and says let not envy that
Devils have riches in hell and I see
things in this one the the Gnostic idea
that somehow the world itself that we
inhabit is hell ultimate that matter is
not our true places of existence but
somewhere is sort of platonic and also
the toasty and sort of bargain that
people made around 1666 to to get a
world of stuff and seeing some
possession by losing a soul yeah but
existed before that and I wonder if that
I play with that a lot in my own thought
and I wonder if that's something that
you found in Milton and what you think
of that passage in particular well
Milton was definitely a prophetic voice
right and I think that's that's a
perfectly reasonable retelling of that
section it's also very much akin to the
story of the Tower of Babel we'll talk
about next week
see the problem with the problem god
it's so complicated see what one of the
things that Jung said about the
transformation of the first millennium
of Christianity into let's say the
second millennium of Christianity was
that Christianity had promised something
like Redemption Universal Redemption
from suffering maybe in the afterlife
but that was kind of a cop-out let's say
because it didn't really solve the
problem of suffering here and now and
you believe that as people had although
although it did many it did many
positive things let's not let's not
forget that it civilized people in a way
that they hadn't been before or you
could make that case but then there was
this underground at the same time
there's this denial of the utility of
material reality that went along with
the spiritualization of mankind in that
in that first in the Christian
millennium there was value left in
material because it had been ignored and
so then Jung believed that the the
collective unconscious
broadly speaking began to be attracted
to the to what had been rejected by the
hyper spiritualization and started to
question whether or not additional value
could be extracted from the material may
be as a adjunct to the spiritual because
maybe true redemption was something like
a proper meeting of the spiritual in the
material which wasn't something that
seemed to be part and parcel of
Christian Christian doctrine up to that
point now maybe what Milton was warning
against was a swing to far right and I
think Milton's point is well-taken
because one of the things that's worth
noting is that you can be perfectly
miserable in a house of gold right I
mean I've known very many wealthy people
very very wealthy people and the problem
see the thing is is that money just
doesn't solve that many problems that
people have people wish it would people
who want to be rich think it will and
the people who want to redistribute
money think it will and I know that
there's nothing to be said for abject
poverty but the problem is is that there
are many see
Arius problems that human beings have
that matter material comfort alone does
nothing to address or almost nothing you
can be perfectly you can have a
perfectly miserable family life and
twenty million dollars and the buffer
that the twenty million dollars puts
between you and the misery is it
sometimes it's not even a buffer it's a
magnifier so melding would warn against
the creation of even the idea of a
material utopia even in principle
something Dostoevsky also recognized as
an error you cannot solve the problem in
that manner and maybe the demonic idea
is that is propaganda that you could now
maybe maybe there is a balance of some
sort because I don't understand if we
were going to build the City of God
let's say well a huge part of the
endeavor would have to be spiritual and
to me that a huge part of that would be
it would have to be something predicated
if not on truth at least not at least on
the willingness of people not to lie to
one another without that all the
material well-being in the world is it's
a facade
it's like gilding a corpse right and I
think that's partly what Melton was
warning against I mean Melton was doing
many more things than he knew of course
because he was a poetic genius of
incalculable genius right right right
right so well you've obviously thought
about such things very much so that was
a very good question so alright everyone
goodnight
you